good afternoon every
and I'm going to be introducing
everybody to
a talk called extending Panthers with
custom types led by will aid if I could
kindly ask you all to please silence
your cellular devices and turn your
notifications off that would be great
and without further ado let's give it up
for will eight everybody thanks for
coming today super excited to talk to
you about extending pandas at the very
first pie data la so just a quick
introduction to what this talk is about
with the last major release of pandas we
introduced the new extension interface
to the system so if you're asking why do
I need to extend pandas this is a good
place to be the purpose of this talk is
to just explain that a little bit more
detail we're not gonna go down until
like how to actually do it with the new
interface so I'll give you some
resources to look at that going forward
but just really want to get you
acclimated with this new feature what it
is shows some examples of where it might
be useful with the caveat this this is
brand new it's still under development
so I wouldn't call it completely stable
at this point but myself and a few of
the other devs of pandas think this is
going to be a pretty killer future going
forward so with that let's talk about
the motivation for this pandas
historically bound to the numpy type
system a numpy great package obviously
responsible for a lot of the other
packages success that you've heard about
here but like any package it's not
without its limitations
so imagery boolean types if you try
storing missing data in an array with
either of those types good luck it's not
gonna happen
and for things like categorical data add
a time a time zone types like that they
don't exist in numpy they do exist in
pandas which you may be familiar with
but that's not done without great effort
to change the internals of the package
to be able to support that kind of
information and you you kind of see that
at the bottom I know it's a little tough
to read on this projector but if you
kind of peek through the source code of
pandas you'll see a lot of instances
like this where we're kind of inspecting
the type of data that we had to figure
out is this categorical is this
daytime timezone and depending on the
answer to that question we may have to
take different approaches to handling
that data which is just kind of
difficult is you want to add more more
types like this okay
so before we get into this - let's talk
about a little terminology we have
extension type and you know a type just
like Python numpy like concept still
applies there we do allow creation of
types using names which is a little bit
different than what you'll see the numpy
but you can do as type foo if you had a
foo type in the system and be able to
instantiate your type that way the main
thing that we have in the extension
interface is the extension array so this
is where you'll end up writing most of
your code if you decide to go down this
path and potentially implement your own
extension we don't really make it so
that you know we don't put a lot of
restrictions on how you can construct
these but they do need to be convertible
to an umpire arrays of one limitation
that we have right now and you know if
you're thinking of working with the
multi-dimensional extensions it's still
fine as long as it can be converted to a
one-dimensional numpy array at some
point and I'll show you an example of
this later because that's essentially
what the internals of panda is going to
be expecting so this is you know really
an interface to you know if you sign up
and follow these rules and everything
and can convert your data to a one
dimensional numpy array in some form or
another
you know we're trying to guarantee that
the internals will be able to understand
your custom type and deal with that
appropriately this last point here
direct from tom Alex Berger who's one of
the core maintainer z' of pandas and did
a lot of work on the extension interface
what we're trying to move to is make a
series of container for an array like
thing historically a series is again
really been bound to like the numpy
array but we don't want that to be
necessarily bound to just the numpy
array we want to support you know all
different types of arrays so a series is
just a container for an array whether it
be a numpy type array or array of your
own building so
with that I just want to show you some
actual applications and some of these
you can use today on mastering pandas if
you wanted to one of the first ones is
in a jar na and again as mentioned if
you tried to store any data or missing
data in an integer array with numpy it
will implicitly cast it to float so
let's illustrate this upfront today your
values all the way on the left let's
assume this is an umpire array
contiguous in memory we again cannot
store integers in this array because we
have missing data so we have 100 as a
float we have a missing value and we
have to dot o also float pandas is that
internals box in the middle and then to
the right you get outputs of certain
operations so some min max okay so
nothing too crazy going on here what we
do with integer na is use two arrays
we're a one is storing the actual values
we're applicable and the other is
essentially a bit mask of sorts saying
is this a missing value yes or no so
compare the two sides of the screen here
again on the left you have one array
with missing data that's has to be a
float on the right you have array with a
one array with integer values doesn't
really matter what that middle value is
could be anything and then you have a
mask you know essentially saying is this
missing data or not and with that with
the new extension interface you can
essentially still take that information
and define a way to convert that to a
one dimensional numpy array that the
internals will understand and be able to
produce the output that you want being
you know three one and two for some max
but again the big difference here is
you're working with integer data you're
not getting cast to float now if you're
looking closely at it you may realize
that there's potentially some overhead
with having a second array to store the
mask and that's true but we'll talk
about that in a little more detail
because if used correctly you can
actually get some pretty significant
memory savings through extension Ares as
well but in this case you know the big
thing you're looking at is precision by
not having too
to float so how do we actually do this
well again I mentioned today you could
do this on master we have these types in
there already and all you have to do is
use a capital I for int okay so just
going through the lines of code real
quick on line three here you see a
traditional construction of a series of
what you want to just be integers with
missing data your output is not integers
by any means you have the floats and the
missing value in between if though you
specified the d-type as a capital I in
64 you will see that your values are not
stored as floating or they're still
stored as in 64 with that missing value
in between and again behind the scenes
we really have won a race during the
values as in and another storing the
mask but through the extension interface
you could see how this produces a
correct output that you want at that
point in time and you could do that with
all the sizes signed and unsigned
integers today so again I mentioned
before there's potentially a little bit
of overhead with having an extra ray but
not always you can actually get some
reductions out of this as well in
typical usage so let's say you know we
had some scenario where we want to
create a series of unsigned in 16 values
we'll do it in the range to the high end
of that range so on line 4 here you see
we've constructed our series our type is
still unsigned integer 16 the moment
that we assign a missing value we've
been implicitly upcast to float 64
assuming you're on a 64-bit system not
cool extension array all right same kind
of thing all we're doing is declaring an
unsigned int 64 with the capital u and
the capital I internally in pandas this
is the extension array that can manage
integer data with missing values as well
do the same kind of assignment on line 9
here I introduce a missing value into my
series it does not implicitly cast
anything so I've kept the same D type
throughout and you can see in terms of
the number of bytes used here between
line 11 which is the series with just
standard integer types and and 12 which
is the extension integer types that the
number of the amount of memory occupied
is is pretty significant in terms of
savings so you do the math there you're
about thirty seven point five percent of
what you would have if you had that
implicit cast to float 64 now you can do
a lot of other tricks as well to maybe
prevent that cast and up cast to 64 bits
but if you just kind of do a normal
programming paradigm that's what you get
so you can again also leverage something
like this for significant memory savings
let's talk about another application of
extension of arrays this is cyber cyber
pandas so this was built mostly by Tom
Alex Berger who I mentioned before is
done a lot of work on the extension
interface this is an external package to
pandas so this is not something that
comes with pandas itself but what cyber
pandas does is give you the concept of
an IP array and again if we go back to
that comment about a series being a
container of an array like thing an IP
array is a extension array of just
holding IP addresses really doesn't
matter what's in there so just you know
very simply you see on lines 5 & 6 here
standard construction rules apply you
can build a series of IP arrays and a
data frame with IP arrays so nothing too
crazy going on there where it gets cool
that was when you could start using
custom attributes right so here at the
top you see construction of IP addresses
from integer values and then we have
defined or cyber pandas actually is to
find a I P accessor so you may be
familiar with this if you've worked with
string types or date/time types if
there's like a dot STR and a dot DT that
you'll see appended to a lot of series
here it's dot IP and what you can do is
to find custom attributes like is na or
it is ipv6 all right you see the values
there with the IP addresses the first
one of them is missing its
essentially 0.090 to zero that's a
normal I P address and then you can
differentiate pretty easily between ipv4
and ipv6 again with a method that you've
defined on your extension all right all
right one last demo here since we
started on the concept of memory savings
before this is one that I've actually
been working on that's why I put a big
asterisk of under developments not
complete yet but something you could
also take a look at if you're interested
to see how this is getting implemented
bid array so talking about bid array and
taking us back to integer and a really
quick mention that you know with the
existing integer and a implementation
you essentially have two arrays that
you're managing behind the scenes which
if you have the same size type could add
or will add a little extra memory
overhead to what was there previously
but what you can do with bit array if
you're not familiar with the package is
take booing masks like you have 0 1 0
here they're all occupying individual
addresses in memory so at least one byte
that you're dedicated to each of those
but with bit array what you could do is
start working down the bit level and bid
array will do the heavy lifting for you
of taking something like 0 1 0 which is
a sequence of 3 bits and being able to
figure out that okay this is really
mapping to some kind of array where the
second element in the array you know it
is true or false or whatever you won't
want to mean in that situation so what
you see here is you could theoretically
with something like bit array make your
second array much smaller than what it
was previously you know take the 8 bits
that you have in a byte and really like
maximize them instead of requiring each
boolean value to occupy one byte memory
so this could be pretty significant
memory savings and I mentioned the same
points here one thing I talked about
previously was that you just really have
to define some kind of serialization
from whatever your
custom memory storages that you're doing
behind the scenes to a one-dimensional
umpire array so here are some simple
methods again this is under development
I'm not saying this is what they'll end
up being but just to showcase for you
that's literally all that's going on
behind the scenes is you know we have
this mask that's essentially a bit array
array we have a bunch of values and when
it comes time to have the pandas
internals start working and interpreting
that data will essentially you know take
that and combine it into a one
dimensional array that knows that the
second value is missing the first value
and the the last value of that array or
one and two respectively so why would we
do something like that well I touched on
this before if you do this correctly you
can get really significant memory
savings again we've taken that second
array which was just a mask of zero and
ones and you can reduce the memory
footprint of that by up to a factor of
eight simply moving from bytes to bits
let's say you had instead of an integer
array you had a boolean array backed by
a bit array so you wanted a boolean
array that could store any values you
could theoretically have two bit arrays
which would essentially give you all
that same information that before you
would have to store and a really
expensive like float64array so something
like that could save you up to
potentially 16 times the amount of the
memory that you would have just by
having some kind of extension array
interface like that so those are just
some quick use cases again I wanted to
familiarize you with this not
necessarily going to go too deep into
the actual implementation but if you are
interested in learning more about it or
seeing more obviously the pandas
documentation is a great place to start
with that there's also extension rates
for pandas which Tom Alex Berger wrote
kind of the initial article that
introduced this whole new interface so
you can you can see what's going on
there and I've also provided a link to a
talk by Eva Coyne where he kind of goes
in a little bit more detail about you
know what are the things that you
actually need to build out in your
extension type to make sure that you can
interact
with the interface and you know build
your custom type or your custom memory
management underlying the arrays that
you'd like to report off of and with
that take any questions that you have
[Applause]
thanks for your talking yeah
what are you storing in your integer
array I assume it's not a question mark
for the missing value I'll say I don't
know I don't care but there has to be
something there if you're using an
integer array yeah I think it could just
be any kind of sentinel or could be a
value that you really just don't care
about I'm not sure that might go a
little that's probably a little further
into the metal than I've actually looked
at myself I see but I don't see how you
can know what integers the user doesn't
care about that would be the mask right
the match tells you I don't care about
that second so if you think about those
two side-by-side and again when you
actually get to the point where you're
like condensing that them down into a
one dimensional array that mask is your
indication that whether it's zero and
that question mark or some other kind of
sentinel like it really doesn't matter
like that's an instruction the end user
that that's the missing value so that's
where you really start using you know
two arrays to kind of get at that get
around that limitation that you can't
store any data in ah you know a juror a
numpy cool thank you yeah this is this
is really cool stuff I'm excited for it
to land my question are you aware of
anyone working on this in the area of
making text perform better I know that
text being sort of strings being an
object D type has been obtained as far
as memory usage are you aware of like
I'm not personally aware of anything
going on but I wouldn't be surprised if
that's an area that people really focus
on because you know there are a lot of
limitations that working with string
data and just having a generic least or
an object type in pandas so there's
certainly a lot to be done there kind of
our hope and actually this is a really
good question like
our goal is not to put all of these
items into pain to disperse a like we
want to have a library of like external
packages that you know the community
could contribute you know certain types
of extension arrays - and you saw that
with cyber pandas I think don't quote me
on this but I think Astro PI are some of
the people with that might have done
something to give you a unit of measure
with each of your arrays which is super
important in astrophysics but also a lot
of applications so I don't there's
nothing internal with pandas right now
on that front but we'd love
contributions if it's something that you
or anyone else in this room is thinking
about this is really the way to do it
and again it doesn't need to be done in
pan as we would love to have a library
of external packages that can kind of
focus on particular aspects of data
processing imagine
it's my big beat are related hey what
the last leak was something about a
penderson arrow and number so it's arrow
something we come inside panda so as to
be in Stara library well arrows an
external library West McKinney who
started pandas ever long back we support
for arrow inside panda oh it would be an
extension
yeah I don't know exactly how that
implementations going to work out but we
do want to like start supporting that
more I mean you you can kind of read it
through the certain formats today but
long term will be great to use that
memory format as well I don't know if
that is going to be an extension array
or just kind of the implementation that
we move towards internally over time but
however that actually gets implemented
there's certainly a long term vision to
move towards arrow to start working with
some of the internals and using that for
memory management yeah
thank you for the talk well yeah if you
can go back to the slide you are earlier
well you show the mass carry and the
Eternals box this one back one more yep
that's so uh so in this example here
you're going from a vector to a scalar
value right what happens if after the
internals box processes the data I again
have a vector yeah what I need a mask on
the other side as well or what happens
wait okay yeah they'll go there when I
was obviously be to preserve the D type
that's coming in so if you're sending in
a D type here of like the integer n a we
would love to return an integer in a as
well yeah right so and again think about
this way like you're kind of more or
less serializing your integer n a when
you pass it to internals so the same way
that you have to send it into a numpy
array for the internals the process you
have to be able to understand that numpy
array that gets returned when it comes
back so it's it's more or less on the
extension author to be able to handle it
but the goal is again as long as you can
like convert to it an umpire rail you
could theoretically losslessly come back
from it which the pandas internals would
give you so if the extension is coded
correctly and instead of you know
aggregating to a scaler or something
like that you get a series or whatever
you'd still the internals as is today
we'll give you an umpire way back and
then your extension array would
understand how to essentially DC realize
that numpy array back into your original
implementation mm-hmm yeah
so if if I write my own type do I get
this mask to represent missing data
no this mask is something you have to
implement yourself so if you actually
look in and as I mentioned with the
integer and a stuff it is already
actually in pandas master so if you look
at pandas core data raised in the source
code you'll see how it manages that but
it's it's not like you just
automatically get a get a free mask
because not everything needs a mask
either like we're gonna have extension
types that don't work with missing data
per se so that's not something that's
guaranteed it's something you as an
altar have to code in yourself Thanks
yeah
have you guys up if you guys already
played with whether different extensions
are composable or able to both be
applied to the same item like for
instance you needed IP addresses where
na is also required can you repeat that
question oh if I fully understand when
you start using one of these extension
ah are you pretty much locked into doing
things the way that extension does or if
you have the need for two different they
four behaviors that are provided by two
different extensions is there any way to
have them both I don't know if the
internals of Pena's would be able to
guarantee anything about that I assume
you could do some kind of composition
with another extension that would be
composed or inherit from two other
extensions in some form or fashion but I
guess so your example like you're asking
if you wanted to store like missing
values like instead of storing a 0.0.0.0
for the IP address like you may want to
store it with a mask instead and and
kind of compose that from an existing IP
type and not sure that's a better
example okay yeah you could do something
like that I think that burden would kind
of fall back on the extension author to
be able to handle something like that I
don't think pandas is going to do
anything internally to kind of infer or
compose types from various extension
types but certainly as an author I think
you could do something like that yeah
so it looked like if you wanted to use
your own types in a single series it
seemed pretty straightforward you could
use D type or you can use as type how
does that work if like you're talking
about bit masking between multiple
columns how does that work that masking
between multiple columns yeah bit
masking like if you had a series of
true/false billions well keep in mind
that you're gonna be we definitely want
to separate like the work that we're
gonna do in the extension land from like
the the pandas user-facing end so if you
go back to an example like this like I
think line six is more or less what
you're talking about right so you know
compare lines three in line six here
line three you know you're trying to
inject missing data into a series and
essentially you're getting coerced into
flow 64 now if you wanted to construct
something that was like true missing
false true missing you would essentially
do that similar to what you do on line
six you'd say build me a series of
true/false na and H or false whatever D
types gonna be bull na or whatever that
extension type is called so that that
all again from like a pandas user
perspective should be seamless now the
extension should be responsible for
being able to interpret you know what
those values are and in that case I
think I just said like six values like
you're gonna have a mask that you know
is noted in two places that there's a
missing value and wherever else that's
going to store the actual boolean value
so your extension rate will implicitly
like be able to take something like this
as long as it's implemented correctly
and store that internally in the memory
format that needs but I just want to be
clear to like you know you're not you
typically wouldn't want to directly
instantiate like your extension or Ayami
you could like like you've seen in cyber
pandas here like IPRA is an extension
right we're instantiating it directly
and then kind of passing it to pandas
but on the flip side if you're just a
general pandas user and you
just want that to work automatically you
can do it directly through a serious
constructor and as long as the the type
is specified as part of that you know
that should start firing off and
interfacing with your extension
appropriately to make sure that that
data gets stored the way it needs to
does that answer your question yeah
anything else
cool well thanks everybody appreciate
you from the back